well my name is Yuri Zhirkov
senior fellow of macmillan center and
the foreman
you credit to the United Nations I have
a privilege today to host them to
introduce my good friend and brilliant
politician and diplomat ambassador
Miguel Abdulaziz ambassador had a
brilliant career both domestically and
internationally well if you look at his
CV he was well the personal diplomatic
adviser to President Mubarak for seven
years and today I will challenge him
about that period all too well to
explain most probably at the carpet or
something you are going to share with us
I do understand that you are an acting
diplomat is much more limited for you
than for me to speak on something but so
it will be interesting for the public
well to to share with us on on that
period of time because you was a Sherpa
the organizer of different talks on the
israeli-palestinian issue Middle East
settlement the the Arab us dialogue so
it would be very much no father interest
so ambassador because this was firmly
resent of his country and to the United
Nations and it was a brilliant period
for him and for the United Nations
because he stand it behind the major
decisions if if you know something about
this building process so he stands
behind of the creation of peace building
commission and and whatever Iran that
well after that he was invited by the
Secretary General Ban ki-moon to be his
his deputy undersecretary general for
Africa so
interesting for us also to hear from him
about the developments in Africa and now
well we have a privilege to to welcome
ambassador Aziz as the ambassador and
observer representative of the League of
Arab states most probably one of the
most vulnerable regions in the world
where a lot of conflicts are going on
Syria Yemen is really Palestinian and
many many others so well of course we
will be interested in ambassador's
vision on the developments in the region
of Arab states both on the on the whole
region covered by the Arab states and
the sub regional level because we know
that there are sub regional
organizations like Maghrib like the Gulf
country cancel any personal golf so all
of them they are part of the big Arab
world and of course the the title I
invited ambassador well to share about
the Arab League in the World Order
nobody knows what the New World Order is
going to be and it's it will be
interesting to hear the division of
ambassador on the New World Order and
the role of the Arab world in that World
Order I will come back after the the the
statements the presentation by
ambassador who is my question and then
we will ask you to raise your questions
I have a list of the provoking questions
to him today and I guess that ambassador
is ready for that ambassador we have a
floor well thank you very much
ambassador Sergey and I would like to
start here by expressing deep
appreciation to the
McMillon Center for inviting me to make
this presentation within its global
governance series and to thank in
particular my dear friend and a longtime
colleague his Excellency ambassador ISA
gave for this sir quant introduction
thank you very much actually when
ambassador sir gave invited me to come
to Yale University on the 31st of
October I thought I was invited to a
Halloween party
but and maybe this is still the case but
after all but I promised that I would
not say anything here's that scary after
you during my presentation or in the
question-and-answer as someone who has
been associated with various aspects of
the work of the United Nations for more
than 20 years of my diplomatic career 15
of them on national capacity
representing an Arab Muslim and
non-aligned country Egypt and five years
leading the United Nations Secretariat
work in Africa and now representing the
League of Arab states in the United
Nations for more than one year and I
will try to put all my experience in
national regional and international
multilateral framework to assess and
address the role that the League of Arab
states is playing and in the New World
Order I believe that you have at least
the basic information about the League
of Arab states which I will refer to
later in some occasions as last as it is
abbreviation la s so we call it last and
its inception and evolvement as a
regional player in the international
scene particularly its participation as
observer since 1950 in the activities of
the United Nations General Assembly
Security Council and Economic and Social
Council
and their subsidiary bodies and the
intergovernmental negotiating structures
and the Arab world today remains a
region blessed with a plethora of
unhonest opportunities and enormous
economic potential and at the same time
burdened by precedented political
transformations and social challenges
the conflicts in Palestine Iraq Syria
Libya Yemen and elsewhere have all had
regional implications far beyond their
borders
and upheavals and intrastate conflicts
that followed the so called the Arab
Spring have according to the United
Nations resulted in a net loss over 614
billion u.s. dollars in economic
activity in the region between the years
2011 and 2015 fiscal expenditures that
would otherwise have been invested in
industry in infrastructure and education
have been diverted to meet the pressing
social demands and immediate
humanitarian needs of populations
throughout the region
multiple Arab governments also find
themselves compelled to allocate even
more resources to combat the dual threat
of terrorism and violent extremism is
destabilizing their countries and the
overall situation in the Middle East has
been further exacerbated by successive
foreign interventions and interference
in the internal affairs of the Arab
world the restoration of peace and
stability achieving the desired good
governance and inordinate tasks of
Reconstruction in this multiple
emergency situations will thus require
an equally extraordinary political
commitment
on the part of the international
community and that sustained engagement
and support of our partners abroad only
then can the Arab world truly realize
its full potential and focus its
resources on securing its uninterrupted
development and sustained economic
growth while these multiple challenges
may seem at the moment at the moment at
least insurmountable they do not
represent an accurate characterization
of the Arab world which remains for the
most part formidable in its resilience
highly confident in its economic
potential and strongly anchored by the
innovation of its people with a combined
GDP GDP of over three trillion US
dollars a population of more than 400
million a total workforce exceeding 130
million 55 percent of the world's proven
oil reserves and foreign currency
reserves exceeding 1.5 trillion US
dollars the Arab world is undoubtedly an
integral component and export are
exponentially the important player in
the global economy the region is also by
far the world's largest exporter of
energy it sets
astride the global most important
strategic waterways some of its
countries enjoy the world's highest per
capita incomes its Airlines now dominate
the global aviation industry its
sovereign wealth funds are among the
world's largest and most dynamic it will
be the host both of the World Expo in
2020 and the World Cup in 2022 and its
economy is forecast to grow by 3.1
percent this year with the World Bank
estimating that a number of are up
countries
register a solid growth rate between
four and seven percent in 2018 there are
many more aggregate indicators that one
can mention but let me just reflect on
three specific examples that perhaps
best illustrate how the Arab world
despite that challenges and
preoccupations I refer to is evolving
adapting and preparing for the future
the first is in Egypt which recently
embarked on a massive infrastructure
project to expand and develop the civils
canal and it's adjacent corridor with
the aim of positioning itself as an
international hub for global maritime
trade and rent and transportation the
second one is in Saudi Arabia which
recently unveiled an ambitious plan to
develop a new mega city on the red sea
powered solely by clean energy called
neon and with total investments
approaching half a trillion dollars and
the third is in the United Arab Emirates
where the government recently
established a Ministry of artificial
intelligence and announced its called
its countrywide strategy for artificial
intelligence II which the aim with the
aim of placing the UAE at the forefront
of the global revolution in technology
and innovation these three examples
so-called showcase how the Arab world
its leadership and its societies are
endeavouring to remain competitive in an
increasingly globalized world they
demonstrate how the Arab world is
strategically leveraging the
opportunities afforded by globalization
to further develop and diversify its
economies and they illustrate just how
intrinsically integrated the Arab world
has become in today's global economy and
technological landscape on the other
hand and judging from my long urine
experience particularly with the United
Nations Security Council in the 80s and
the 90s and the 2000s it becomes all the
more all the more evident that
contemporary international order is not
anymore governed only by laws and by the
principles upon which the United Nations
was founded it even appears to me that
the rules of international law
international humanitarian law and
international human rights law are
passing through a difficult period in
our world order a period that is
preventing the implementation of some of
its provisions in full and in most cases
casting heavy shadow over the
interactive relation that should connect
global good governance which we aspire
for in the United Nations with global
with regional good governance that we
strive to establish at the regional
level in our regional organizations and
with the good governance governance that
both organizations call upon their
member states to apply within their
territories while respecting fully their
sovereignty and territorial integrity
the Arab world has been one of the most
affected regions as a result of that
gradual change in the world order simple
comparison between the agenda of the
United Nations Security Council in the
80s and its agenda and mm will clearly
reveal that in the 80s about 80% of the
issues before the Security Council will
focus on African issues on the Great
Lakes region on the Sahel region on the
Horn of Africa nowadays about 65% of the
issues before the Security Council are
Arab issues ranging from the question of
Palestine through the situation in Iraq
in Libya Yemen Syria Somalia
Kimora's and others let alone issues
like terrorism violent extremism
fundamentalism non-state actors and
lately the entire Arab differences and
disputes that does not appear in the
United Nations but continue to be dealt
with one way or another among the
countries concerned and sometimes with
the participation of the League of Arab
states one might ask whether this is a
sign of failure of the collective
security system by Arab states and last
that had that had negative impact on
protecting and advancing various aspects
of Arab nationalism which has been the
main objective behind the establishment
of the league in 1945 one might also ask
whether the constant change in checks
and balances in the relations between
superpowers including its increasing
interest in specific areas of the Arab
region for strategic or financial
objectives had an impact on the current
stage of affair in the Arab world or
that the current state of affair is
merely a result of drastic changes
within or between the Arab countries on
the political economic or Human Rights
aspects for further progress there is no
doubt that the new world order had its
impact on each and every country in the
Arab world but looking at the collective
picture we can identify several factors
that might have increased the impact of
the changes in the new world order on
governance both globally and in the Arab
countries at large
this could include international and
regional aspects looking at the
International aspects first and despite
the continued successes in the
lamentation of many UN reforms it is
regrettable to see that the balance of
power within the United Nations Security
Council the organ entrusted with the
maintenance of international peace and
security is still based on post-world
War two
realities without any hope for new
permanent members with veto powers to be
added to its membership in order to
allow the representation of new
political powers including dedicating a
permanent seat with veto power also to
the 22 Arab countries as demanded by the
League summit this in itself puts the
Arab world increasingly under the mercy
of the current permanent members
particularly in dealing with Arab issues
that current permanent members
themselves disagree upon or at least
have clear different interests or
objectives in dealing with it such as a
show Palestine and Syria which had been
increasingly subjected to many vetoes to
protect one party to the conflict or to
support another thus allowing those
crisis situations to continue spreading
massive destruction and prolonging the
humanitarian suffering of Arab
populations on the ground the conflict
in Syria is a case at point seven years
have elapsed since the eruption of the
Syrian uprising in 2011 three special
envoys of the most distinguished calibre
have been appointed by the United
Nations
but the persistent confrontation between
the superpowers in the United Nations
Security Council and the consecutive use
or threat of use of veto is preventing
the Security Council from reaching and
implementing an effective and
comprehensive peaceful solution leaving
the determination of what needs to be
done in the hands of those who has
physical militant
presence on the ground including
superpowers neighboring countries and
others but what is more troubling in
this regard is that this confrontational
mode in the Security Council is impart
resulting in more isolation of the role
of Arab countries and the League of Arab
states in dealing with one of the most
important issues of the Arab world a
closer look on the participation of Arab
states in the negotiating tracks of the
Syrian crisis will only show that
meetings are being held with the
participation of the United Nation
within the Geneva to Sochi and Astana
tracts and all those meetings are
witnessing less and less participation
from the League of Arab states and its
member states some one might say that
the league has chosen to suspend the
membership of Syria from its to suspend
Syria from its membership
thus isolating itself from the process
others might say that the lack of
unified position among the Arab
countries on how best to achieve the
desired political settlement to the
crisis after the uprising is preventing
the league and its members from becoming
an effective partner in the search for
peace but the fact still remains that
the confrontation mode that is
prevailing between the superpowers in
particular between the US and the rest
of the ìiî on one side and the Russian
Federation on the other is resulting in
the current stagnation which is only a
girl aggravating the humanitarian
suffering of the Syrian people the same
situation applies in the Security
Council's dealing with the question of
Palestine and the future of the peace
process in the Middle East the lack of
clarity regarding the components of the
deal of the century this deal that we
keep hearing about
for long and its relation to the
internationally recognized principles
for decades the two-state solution the
land for peace for peace and the Arab
Peace Initiative and the Oslo principles
that the sanctity of the peace process
under the auspices of the quartet with
the United States playing the most
significant role in dealing with the
five final status issues Jerusalem
refugees settlement water and security
all they suffered a severe shock in the
United Nations from the latest decisions
by the American administration to
recognize Jerusalem as a capital of
Israel and to move the American Embassy
to Jerusalem and the consequent decision
to cut funding to UNRWA the United
Nations relief for the refugees and
other activities of the Palestinian
authorities putting the United States
decisions directly into collision course
with the international legitimacy on one
hand and with the Arab Peace Initiative
adopted by the Arab League summit in
2002 and on another this Arab Peace
Initiative
is stating clearly that all Arab
countries are ready to recognize Israel
establish diplomatic relations with it
and normalize the relations when the
independent and viable state of
Palestine is established through free
negotiations between the parties with
East Jerusalem as its capital
this sudden impact decisions by the
American administration outside the
scope of negotiations under the
multilateral tract were globally
perceived as attempting to eliminate two
of the final status issues Sheraton
Jerusalem and refugees and resulted
consequently in an unnecessary
confrontation in the Security Council
spilled over to the general assembly
this confrontation could have been
simply avoided through more clarity
consultations and negotiations with the
Palestinian Authority the Arab countries
and the League of Arab states about the
strategy of the American administration
in dealing with issues that are of
paramount importance to the Arab world
and about the main components of the
deal of the century that everybody is
eagerly anticipating what exacerbates
the situation regarding the question of
Palestine is that while we have just
celebrated the 70th anniversary of the
Universal Declaration on human rights
and with the unanimous adoption of the
2005 outcome document of the General
Assembly establishing new norms like
responsibility to protect and like human
security to prevent recurrence of the
atrocities that were committed in Rwanda
and Srebrenica the global governance
system in the United Nations Security
Council has been even to establish a
monitoring mechanism that aims at
providing protection for the Palestinian
population from the attacks of by the
Israeli Defense Forces while at the same
time providing protection of the Israeli
population from rockets and suicide
attacks launched by Amma's all that and
I am here
citing only two examples leave us within
the United Nations with the impression
that a new Cold War is brewing and
having its negative impact on the global
governance system including its impact
on Arab States yes there is always the
alternative to resort to the General
Assembly as the Parliament of the world
under the famous resolution uniting for
peace but the open threat threats aired
against Member States
who vote one way or another and the
threat to cut assistance or suspend
activities maiden official meetings and
speeches before the Security Council and
General Assembly are being only
construed as threats to global
governance system that could have severe
implications on its credibility and
effectiveness particularly in regions
such as the Middle East
turning to the regional impact of new
world order on the Arab countries and
the Arab League the increasing
international direction towards
enhancing prevention in close
coordination between the United Nations
and regional and sub-regional
organizations in accordance with chapter
8 of the United Nations Charter should
be looked at as a step towards the
effective application of the
co-operative global governance structure
aiming at dedicating more financial and
human resources towards the effective
implementations of the sustainable
development goals targets and education
indicators of the United Nations Global
Agenda 2030 in close cooperation with
its compatible regional and sub-regional
plans and ambitions but if we look into
various regions of the world we will
find that different regions have
different structures in doing so in
Africa for instance and I had the
privilege to serve as Undersecretary of
the United Nations and the special
advisor the second general in Africa one
has to admit that the African continent
came to realize this need for a new
horizon much before the Arab world the
transformation of the organization of
the African Union IAU established in
1963 into the African Union au in 2000
the establishment of the new partnership
for Africa's development the NEPAD into
thousand to as a blueprint for African
development in political economic and
social aspects and the establishment of
2003 of the African peer-review
mechanism Apr M as an internal voluntary
mechanism at the heads of state and
government level aimed at reviewing good
governance at the regional level
including democracy and respect for
human rights all those were were
preliminary steps towards the
endorsement in 2015 at the fiftieth
anniversary of the establishment of the
OAU of
the African Union's agenda 2063 this is
a huge agenda determining the African
sustainable development goals that will
be implemented over for the next 50
years over 10 years tranches that
constitute steps for the poor
implementation and the priority regional
projects necessary to achieve those
goals the most important element in this
exercise is the principles that were
established to guide these processes
which contain constitute an evolvement
of the governance at the regional level
like moving from the principle of
non-interference to the principle of non
indifference thus allowing the AU
and at sub regional organizations to
interfere in the case in case of severe
violations of human rights
just to mention as an example in the
arab world
the charter of the arab league endorsed
in the principles of an Arab homeland
while fully respecting the sovereignty
of the Member States and the established
consensus as the basic rule for decision
making in its organs thus allowing each
individual member not to be bound by
decisions that he or she did not agree
to this rule continues to exist but in
sharp contrast with
answers achieved through cohesion and
mutual concessions as it is being done
in the African Union many results have
been cited however by scholars to
strengthen c2 to the stagnant situation
in the Arab world and its relation to
the spread of conflict situation first
it the sharp contrast in wealth between
countries of the Arab region and the
fear of some wealthy countries to be
obliged to share their wealth with less
fortunate states beyond the
internationally agreed percentage in
that the United National Development
structure second the many wars that our
region passed through and the external
alliances associated with it including
1948 1956 67 73 the iran-iraq war the
invasion of Iraq to Kuwait Operation
Desert Storm the invasion of Iraq from
by the United States the American
bombardment of Libya and lastly the
no-fly zone requested by the Arab League
resulting in a massive NATO operation on
Libya until the 31st of October 2011 all
these wars were associated with many
alliances that were created by different
Arab countries with different global and
super powers which gave those allies
some role big or small that should have
been played by fellow Arab countries and
if the Arab collective security system
was functioning well third that the many
failed efforts to unite at sub regional
level or even as a Plaza as a portion of
sub region some scholars claimed that
the lack of sub regional structures
similar to that created by the African
Union such as Sadek in the side in the
South eco
in the West he got in the East and the
historic and community also in the East
and others is to blame but let us always
remember that Arab attempts have been
made in this regard and failed in
achieving its objective the Arab Maghreb
Union between Algeria Libya Mauritania
Morocco and Tunisia was established in
1989 but now it can't be seen as an
active partner neither in Africa nor in
the Arab world the same applies to the
Gulf Cooperation Council established in
1981 as a regional intergovernmental
political and economic union consisting
of all six Arab cantar up States in the
Arabian Gulf it made some significant
strides and still making despite
increasing differences among its member
states about the scope of cooperation
and about how to fend the Iranian fears
campaign to interfere in the internal
affairs of the GCC members of Gulf
Cooperation Council its occupant and
occupation by Iran of the three Emirati
Islands and its continued pursuit of
nuclear weapons
a quick analysis and comparison of the
role that is being played by the African
and Arab sub regional alliances and
organizations would confirm that sub
regional alliances are important in
shaping and implementing governance
structures fourth the deep sense of
frustration in the Arab world about the
lack of political horizon to settle the
most acute problems in the region the
Palestinian question the Syria Libya
Yemen Iraq Somalia and the different
impacts that the continuation of these
hotspots impose on different Arab
countries including on issues of borders
management refugees migration security
and many other aspects
is failing among Arab among Arab
populations characterized by frustration
and despair is only fueling
fundamentalism violent extremism and
feeding into a spread of terrorism v the
high uncertainty about the regional
balance of powers following the
aftermath of the 2003 US invasion of
Iraq and following the 2011 uprisings
with its negative social and economic
impacts particularly in the absence of
clearly articulated criterias in this
regard resulting in many
misunderstandings and sensitivities
between countries of the region
competing to play leading roles using
financial means or political alliances
or military might six the skyrocketing
arms import to the region in sales for
which the United States and its European
allies are competing which are linked in
part to the fear of military
confrontation with Iran on one hand and
to the failure to address the nuclear
file of both Israel and Iran including
in the failure of the establishment of a
nuclear weapon-free zone in the Middle
East despite a clear consensus that was
agreed in 1995 review and extension
Conference of the non-proliferation
treaty NPT and reconfirmed in the
outcome of the 2002 2010 review
conferences 7 the sharp differences
among Arab countries about how best to
deal with terrorism particularly when it
involves actions to be taken against
terrorists that belong to non-state
actors and organizations that are
utilizing religious or civilization as
considerations to justify their
terrorist act
it is the lack of unified position in
dealing with organizations such as Hamas
jihad Ansar Bayt al-maqdis
the Muslim Brotherhood despite the vast
contribution by Arab countries in the
global fight against terrorism through
the United Nations there is particularly
no arab specialized structure - or force
to combat terrorism including to cut
debts funding to prevent foreign foreign
terrorist fighters and to prevent any
support to these organizations and
actors ladies and gentlemens have
incited some and not all of the
considerations that are surrounding any
and affecting Arab good governance I can
only end on the personal capacity state
that overcoming those factors is a
daunting task for regional and
international actors even in optimistic
scenarios progress towards de-escalation
and stability in the Arab region is
likely to be incremental slow and uneven
nonetheless there are concrete steps
that regional and international actors
can explore to mitigate the dangers of
those conflict escalations on top of
those actors is the League of Arab
states that is currently undergoing a
very ambitious reform to enhance its
ability to assist its member states in
overcoming those hurdles and to
coordinate their efforts within a
framework that eliminates the underlying
causes of conflict and coordinate the
efforts of the Abijah Arab governments
to address the challenges mentioned
above and many others but let us be
clear the reform and success of the
League of Arab states will depend on how
strong the support it will get from the
government of its the governments of its
member states and on whether
Secretariat would be allowed by member
states to play its role in promoting
creative way and ways and means to
implement strategies and plans agreed
upon by member states and shaping new
alliances to serve achieving the lofty
objectives of them organizations ladies
and gentlemen I hope I did not over
expand in presenting this mixed pictures
about the Arab League in the New World
Order there are many other things that
to be said but let me conclude by saying
that there is a lot of potential and a
lot of capabilities in the Arab world
but the Arab world cannot do it alone
partnerships are one essential part of
our plans to succeed and on top of it
our partnership with the United States
and a trust that will such the strategic
partnerships we will be able to
successfully achieve our objectives
Thank You mr. moderator thank you Thank
You ambassador disease thank you for
your comprehensive statement and sharing
with us on your vision and now so I'm
Tanika we're meeting to the questions
and answers so I will not repeat my my
role as Maria I will put just one
question and then I will address the
audience well too well to address you I
have more questions than that but based
on the Oh last sentence about the
partnership work United States is one of
the major player and coming back to your
role as the diplomatic adviser to
President Mubarak where you organize a
lot of the meetings both within
different American ambassador different
American presidents secretary of states
and the different players both in
Palestine in
Israel so Palestine was and remains one
of the catalyst issue not only for the
Arab world Middle East but globally and
of course if if you like well to to
expand the the explanation so well all
this process and all these actors who
were there well you started with Arafat
then you continue with President Abbas
you started with a Bill Clinton ten
continuous President Bush well the
actors and decisions where you feel was
the the the best I will to approach the
any kind of the compromise if ever so I
could you briefly explain us well the
the what happened eighty years when you
were the advisor to Mubarak and the role
of these players including as you said
the partners for the United States which
are crucial partners and I will
demonstrate some some of the pictures of
from the period well president Paris
President Clinton President Obama's in
Yeltsin president Arafat so look
everybody keep enhance as a vision that
to the world the solution is there well
as Mubarak President Clinton look it it
gives us imagination that well guys we
are close to the solution well again our
fault our far was easy to communicate
[Laughter]
but again so we have President Abbas
here
well another Yahoo so look the President
Bush was so friendly with President
Mubarak this is not picture relating to
official pictures of the past so some of
the agreements to cite in Washington
well and you did that so President Obama
President Bush no president Trump met
with the Arab League's so your images
from the past okay
was it easy was it not how the partners
did well to settle Israeli policy any
question which is one of the crucial
well thank you very much for that
question I hope you have time till
tomorrow that I can answer it is you
touch on a very on a very good period of
the dealing with the Palestinian
question in those photos you showed most
of the photos with President Clinton and
actually President Clinton was one of
the presidents of the United States that
played a significant role and tried
really hard to settle the Palestinian
question and I I can testify that in his
last six month of of the presidency he
presented a very comprehensive plan 12
three pages plan on the five core issues
that that I mentioned related to the
settlement of the Palestinian question
and he invited the Israelis and the
Palestinians to Camp David whoa
in that time it was called can be the
two summit
and took place in 2000 sometime around
the summer time I do that if I my memory
is serving me well it was July or August
in the summer but and at that time they
meant American administration decided
that the participant will be limited
only to Palestine and Israel at the time
that was that Egypt and Jordan wanted to
join these negotiations to be able to to
to see firsthand and to participate in
dealing in reaching the desired
agreement why Egypt and Jordan because
they were the only two countries that
have diplomatic relations with Israel
and that have already signed a peace
agreement with them with Israel
but the American administration at that
time so that that based on consultations
with with the sites were by of course
the Palestinian side agreed to the
participation of the two countries but
as Raley side had some doubts about
whether the participation is going to be
helpful or whether the participation is
going to make the Palestinian positions
harder and was going to be like a backup
to the Palestinian position vis-a-vis so
it was decided that this dis conference
would take place only the three parties
United States President Clinton and
President Arafat and the Prime Minister
of Israel at that time and and the
conference discussed and to our
knowledge the information that came out
and we were not participating but the
information that came out of that
meeting was that there was agreement on
four of the core issues which are
borders there
was agreement on issues related to the
borders of the Palestinian state on the
cessation of settlement activities on on
uncertain swap of land about the borders
in order to ensure continuity of land of
the Palestinian new state there was
agreement on security and the United
States at that time if if I remember
correctly agreed to put some four or
five hubs of military forces within the
newly established Palestinian state in
order to be too poor to ensure that
there is no military confrontation is
going to be wrapped in between the the
two sides and on water they agreed on
water and refugees they agreed on the
return of a of a small number of
refugees from outside and on raising
funds to - including from the United
States from the European Union and from
Arab countries in order to have those
refugees settled in their new homelands
and this agreement looks like a
comprehensive solution what happened -
is that after what happened was that
there was no agreement on Jerusalem okay
so the only contentious issue that was
remaining on the table and the borders
dated the borders were based on the
borders of 1967 okay not on the borders
as resolutions of the Security Council -
for two and three three eight and other
resolutions are speaking about the
borders of 1967 not the historical
Palestine borders of 1948 but that was
agreed that was preliminary agreed of
course they were all working under the
principle of nothing is agreed except
when everything
secrete that is the famous principle we
used to have in the UN also and we still
have but the core issue that caused the
differences was erosion because there
were a proposal to divide the
sovereignty over Jerusalem the
sovereignty over land and sovereignty
under underground and then because of
the of the issue of the area surrounding
the Haram Sharif and what they call the
Israelis called the Temple Mount
this area has levels there is a land
level and then there is the underground
so there were proposals related to
dividing the sovereignty and then
swapping the sovereignty between so at
that time this these negotiations
collapsed but at the other as an attempt
to to to to salvage the the process
President Clinton and reached out to
President Mubarak and to to the king of
Jordan and and asked them to interfere
but both of them were reluctant to
interfere because they said that we did
not participate in the negotiations from
its beginning and we were not part of
the agreement that has been reached
regarding the other other side so it is
better that you do continue to deal with
it on them on the on that particular
level and at that particular track and
President Mubarak invited them to serve
shake and decay or to Taba no to Taba
and they came for a continuation of the
negotiations but that was almost in
December 2000 when President Clinton was
almost out and and so that that didn't
really but let me say here as you
mentioned
leaders from all countries also that
Egypt is continuing now with its effort
and president Sisi as well as continuing
with the effort to unify the Palestinian
side the Palestinian front in in Gaza
with the Palestinian front in the West
Bank and to ensure that it is going to
be only one Palestinian state and that
is taking a lot of effort and a lot of
time from the leadership in Egypt as
well as from other Arab countries in in
support of and from president Sisi
himself personally in support of the
Palestinian cause you know that when you
entered the negotiation thank you
so you know that he tried to play a role
as a mediator helping the two states to
find their solution some of the Arab
states they didn't like that and Egypt
was expelled from the League of Arab
states for this activity for a durable
pure olive jar that was in 1970 at 78
years and you came back in the agreement
with with with Israel and let me say
here as you mentioned this that when
Egypt signed the peace agreement with
Israel in 1978 there were two agreements
that were signed one agreement was a
peace treaty between Egypt and Israel by
which agreement Egypt will get back the
occupied territory and would establish
diplomatic relations and normalize with
Israel and the second one was the
framework agreement on the establishment
of a Palestinian independent state and
that framework agreement had the
Palestinians decided to sign it was
establishing the independent Palestinian
state after three years from 1978 it
could have been but that despite that of
course at that time
in Iraq President Saddam Hussein Libya
and others led opposition front Syria at
that time and so they accused the Egypt
of treason and they they they even moved
the headquarters of the League of Arab
states from Egypt to Tunisia and then
Egypt was suspended from the League of
Arab states but coming back to reality
the real identities the only so had had
the Palestinians signed the 1978 second
part they of the peace agreement the
Palestinian state could have been in
existence since 1981 well so can can you
bring some optimism on this settlement
of this crisis which is civilization
crisis called civilization coveri but
any hope that a solution could come soon
well we we are hopeful that that the
American administration is working
really on on a package of proposals or
on a deal of the century that we will be
able to to negotiate but the Palestinian
side is now refraining from engaging in
the process because there are fears that
after the decisions to move the embassy
into Jerusalem and to suspend support
for the Palestinian refugees that what
has come there are fears in the
Palestinian side that what is coming
could be worse and that is and that is
that requires a quick and positive
action from the American administration
to to come back to the bases and to the
agreed principles of the international
legitimacy regarding and the peace
process and to resume we are willing to
resume negotiations anytime
and and but without touching on the
basic principles that have been in
existence with with the participation of
everybody including different American
administrations before okay two short
questions so you mentioned in your
introductory mmm the the problem that
terrorism
you were ambassador to the United
Nations and the audience does know the
question is the being a member of the
Security Council Egypt was selected by
p5 the permanent members to chair the
anti-terrorist committee it happened
because of what Egypt's experienced
educated role in combating terrorism
because to get the support of five
permanent representatives to chair the
main the main committee within Security
Council combating terrorism it was
something why it happened thanks to well
thank you very much I was not the
ambassador of Egypt or any - and it was
selected to Jed that terrorism and
terrorism committee but I brought you
but you brought to the Security Council
through all your ten or more no I mean
Egypt had Egypt and counterterrorism
exactly Egypt had a very very important
initiative in 1981 and as you mentioned
President Mubarak and brought his
picture here he made an initiative in
1981 in the European Parliament in
Strasbourg calling for international
conference to deal with the issue of
terrorism can you imagine that it has
been since 1981 we are now in 2018 there
is no international conference held on
the national on Y on annual base the six
committee legal committee I presided it
seven years ago
the same there is no unanimity well as
still the resolutions they are proposing
to convene this international meeting
proposed by president Park in 1981
because still we do not have the
definition what terrorism is yeah and
that is and that is because we failed to
reach agreement on the comprehensive
agreement of terrorism there in
terrorism there are 13 international
agreement and then the United Nations
came to say that we need to have a
comprehensive agreement on terrorism but
this agreement existed in two articles
of this agreement in article 1 and then
article 16 I was in the 6th committee
when it started and when it ended you
know and and were both lawyers so the
article 1 is the definition of terrorism
and throughout the negotiations there
was always the fear that that we as Arab
countries and are trying to exempt the
national liberation movements from being
labeled as terrorists at the time that
we say that there is the yes there is
this clear distinction between national
liberation movements on one side and
terrorists on the other the second is
related to the status of forces that
while they are combating terrorism and
weather forces that are combating
terrorism could be responsible before
the international criminal system for
actions that are taken during that
combat so these two articles prevented
that we have the comprehensive treaty
but then they are not in nations shifted
in 2005 and came up with Global's
United Nations strategy counterterrorism
strategy yeah and this global strategy
is being reviewed every two years and
and more and more practical measures on
how to deal with the issue of terrorism
and how to address the terrorism based
on the information that has been
gathered during the last two years and
the forthcoming direction that this
issue is is going it is working well but
it does not address the the situations
that are on the ground and when I'm
saying that Egypt now is in in the
middle of of a strong battle with
terrorism in Sinai Peninsula and and
against the Muslim Brotherhood and their
supporters and against Islamic
fundamentalist and that's why maybe also
in the Security Council they took that
into consideration along with other
considerations thank you I have at this
stage my last question and then I
address the audience well to raise their
question so in your capacity as
ambassador of a legal for Arab states
well the human rights you mentioned in
your introductory about the priority of
human rights for the League of Arab
states so we know that the Muslim world
the Arab states the they adopted the
Arab charity of human rights
what is that the alternative to
Universal Declaration of Human Rights or
is a complementarity to the Universal
Declaration of Human Rights because a
lot of the different interpretation of
that stance so different human rights
for one part of the world
and for another part of the world or
what is that no it's not an alternative
it's not at all an alternative
to the Universal Declaration of Human
Rights and it is within the application
of the human of the Universal
Declaration of Human Rights you run into
situations that you have to custom its
implementation according to the
character characteristics and
specificities of the culture of the
society that you are addressing and to
address those human rights obligations
that are coming in the Declaration in a
predominantly Muslim part of the world
you have to take into considerations
other other societal and other social
and other intellectual aspects so it is
widening the scope and providing the
interpretation and providing the
supplement supplementary provisions that
would allow and facilitate the
implementation of the Universal
Declaration of Human Rights and other
treaties like the Geneva Conventions
like other other principles the
responsibility to protect human security
all those are also encompassed within
those this kind of treaty that is aimed
at facilitating our adherence and our
obligations in the international thank
you for for that for it was just you who
explained because I knew the the answer
because I read the the Charter are
absurd of human rights were in the in
the preamble is well written that
respecting United Nations Charter and
Universal Declaration of Human Rights so
he says yeah well so but I wanted you to
explain thank you
yes thank you very much Salam alaikum
you articulated many challenges and Arab
unity in the political sphere and
clearly there there are but how about
spheres such as Education Culture
[Music]
communication language etc and also are
there any pending applications to the
Arab League second part pending
applications to the Arab League no there
are no pending applications I don't know
what you're referring to if you are
referring to South Sudan South Sudan did
not apply for the membership of the
League of Arab states and and do you are
you referring to somebody else no no we
did not receive an application from Chad
yet yeah maybe it was it's coming maybe
you know better on this front but on the
issues of education and culture it's
there are there is an ecosoc in the arab
league an Economic and Social Council
for the Arab countries that is very much
specialized on economic and social
issues including all issues related to
education and and and culture and there
are council councils of Ministers that
meet two times a year on education and
can ministers of culture meet two other
times a year in the Arab League to
discuss the common issues that are
in the international arena if there are
any specific concerns or specific issue
you would like to ask about our be more
than happy to further elaborate it is
successful within the the application of
the international norms that are being
decided by collectively by the United
Nations for for instance what is
happening in UNESCO it's getting
discussed and we select what is what
needs to be applied and what needs to be
taken into consideration and the Arab
ministers sit down and draw action plans
and put strategies and countries
implement and then we come back they
come back with like the implementation
of of the sustainable development goals
there are 17 sustainable development
goals I hope you heard about them it's
and one of them is education and all
countries have to submit reports we call
it a via NARS the voluntary national
report and there to some to up a meeting
called the high-level political forum
and there is going to be a summit level
on the high-level political forum in
2020 where countries will present their
reports on education because it is
without education and health care you
cannot build a healthy society and that
is one of the one of the strongest so
that education and culture are fully
encompassed within the 17 sustainable
development goals that are going to be
reviewed in the high-level political
forum at the summit there are some
partial reviews happening every year at
the ministerial level but at the summit
level in the year 2020
thank you other question please thank
thank you very much ambassador there are
now you know currently made three major
humanitarian crises within the arab
world you know Yemen
being one you know and and member one
member of the leak is basically
besieging another member and when you
look at Gaza Egypt could easily open the
border and help the Gaza population and
the third one is you know at least the
Syrian civil war is nearing an end a
very unfortunate end but at least what
are the plans of the Arab League States
regarding the Italy province to helped
humanitarian crisis in that region so
I'm just basically looking you know yes
you have the Palestinian issue you have
all these very lofty goals but how what
are you doing regarding the currently
existing humanitarian crisis within the
league we are part of part of a bigger
organization which is the United Nations
of course we attend all meetings of
wache of the of the office of
humanitarian assistance of the United
Nations we attend the pledging
conferences that are being held with
regard to all the conflicts that you
mentioned with regard to Yemen will
regard to Gaza and and together for
instance on UNRWA there have been a
conference in the United Nations and and
the gap that is resulting from the
American withdrawal of 300 million u.s.
dollars that used to be paid every year
has been almost covered by Arab
countries at the time that we are not
responsible for the for the for the
misery that the Palestinian people or
that the Palestinian refugees are
suffering there are those who are
responsible because of the Balfour
Declaration because of what actions have
been taken taking action on the ground
but the Arab countries are doing their
share in trying to mitigate the impacts
of the of the humanitarian crisis the
same is applying also with regard to to
Yemen and with the Syrian tract there
has been many many meetings that have
been held in the UN and many funds that
have been contributed by Arab countries
within the UN structures because Arab
League cannot deliver humanitarian
assistance in Italy those who can to let
deliver as a United Nations apparatus of
humanitarian assistance that is by law
it is protected and by law it is capable
of providing this humanitarian
assistance so rest assured that we are
doing whatever we can do financially
even though we we are not responsible
maybe we are responsible in part because
we did not do enough to settle it
politically but but we are doing what we
can do financially through the United
Nations assistance system
the Arab League like the United Nations
is an organization that is run by member
states so the Secretariat and the
representatives of the organization do
not exert pressure on member states the
member states exert pressure on the
Secretariat to be honest and and that's
why it is coming it's it's it's there
there are other partners outside the
Arab League that are talking to those
concerned about this issue and I'm sure
that that this kind of international
consultations on that will yield dessert
results that's what I can say within the
Security Council is the base exactly
focus on those who could diminish the
problems there including this the
country you mentioned thank you and
thank you for being with us ambassador
um the Arab League has been coming to
Moores there's more scrutiny on the Arab
League in terms of how much support it's
been providing for many of the countries
and abroad and previously our Musa
always claimed that they have very
limited budget in terms of how much they
could spend so to what extent do you
think that's limiting the Arab League
from conducting its operations in the
Arab world and then secondly there's
also been increasing scrutiny on the
Arab League in terms of call me al
arabiya like Arab nationalism and terms
of how it's pushing for that I'm just
curious to hear your view on these two
points okay
regarding the budget yes it is it is
true that in order to run
such an organization like the Arab
League you need to have the proper
budget for this for the activities of
the league the there is a situation
whereby budget does not get paid in full
and the Arab League and not even half
the budget is paid important and we are
now approaching for instance November of
2018 less than half of the budget have
been paid but the Arab League charter
does not include any system or like the
United Nations Charter in the United
Nations if you don't pay the budget for
one fiscal year you get suspended from
voting so you go to press the button to
vote the button doesn't work you press
the button to speak it doesn't work you
pay you you work that is not prevented
as I will just answer the question the
Arab League is acting under the
supervision and the sovereignty of its
member states it's like also the issue
of the rule of consensus decision
consensus in the United Nations means
that we sit down and we agree to - -
everybody gives and take and then we
have everybody stand high and then lower
their demands then we reach an agreement
and reach consensus and the Arab League
consensus could be that we reach this
level but somebody decide that it is not
going to be bound by it and that is
allowed in the system of the Arab League
so this is these are all things related
to the reform process
that is undergoing I referred to it my
statement there are they are considering
member states are considering all those
aspects in the reform package that is
being negotiated now in the record it
would take a couple of years and I'm
sure it will come out as much as you
want to see thank you and the last
question we'll have a chance to
communicate an ambassador after that
during the reception informally so hello
ambassador so my question is you think a
main point of your talk was that it
seems that the Arab world needs a lot of
assistance from the outside countries
and partnerships with our other nations
but I'm in be interested to know what do
you believe an ideal partnership it
would be what would these Arab states
get from these partnerships what sort of
actions would occur partnerships within
these nations and then my second
question be I guess what is your how do
you feel about you know Arab states
seeming to require help from other
nations to resolve some of these issues
and not I guess being able to do it on
their own
[Music]
yes what would these both these states
get from these partnerships I believe
was the your closing statements you said
through partnerships they will achieve
their goals as I mentioned at the
beginning a lot of resources and a lot
of funds potential what we want the
partnership for is a partnership for
progress and for the future okay it is
not that we are asking for hands
handouts from anybody we are not asking
for financial assets
maybe some members will ask for
financial assistance but but that is
being dealt with because you know in the
Arab League
we have half of almost nine countries
out of the 22 are members of the African
Union and the rest are not and it is
just happening that those that are
members of our inner are the less for
less fortunate countries and content
including Somalia Comoros Mauritania and
others that might need financial
assistance so they get the financial
assistance through other channels
through the United Nations through the
African Union through and sometimes
through voluntary contributions from the
rich Arab countries that are that
include in their in their strategic
plans assistance to other less fortunate
countries so but partnership should be
divided into partnership political
partnership meaning of mutual interests
not only fulfilling interests of one
side and not domination by one side if
you know what I mean yeah this is on
earth so I'm not gonna say and and so
this is what the partnership was looking
for partnership among equals okay
partnership towards political progress
toward economic progress towards social
progress that is for both sides of
course okay so that's one and the one
the other one is
funding it is it is as I said in
answering the question of the budget it
should be funded activities of the Arab
League should be fun I was when I came
first to work for the Arab League I was
struck to know that the budgets of the
Arab League is sixty million dollars per
year when I was undersecretary general
in the United Nations I was running
African affairs
I had a loan under might and I wouldn't
say how much but more than half of this
budget as a special sector that is
working within a global organization
with all the GDP GDP and with all the
the the funds and the sovereign wealth
funds that we are having here so reform
of these issues is very important and a
trust that it will yield the desired
result well let me have to thank
ambassador Aziz for being today with us
and he is open to continue the informal
[Applause]
[Music]